el conflicto en afganistán se agrava con
la retirada de las tropas de
estadounidenses el presidente afgano
afgano aseguró este lunes que la salida
de los oficiales que calificó como
abrupta coincide con el recrudecimiento
de la violencia y el avance del grupo
insurgente la razón de nuestra situación
actual fue que se tomó una decisión
repentina del retiro de las tropas
internacionales y le dije al presidente
de eeuu que respeto su decisión porque
era su decisión pero sabía que tendría
consecuencias y la gestión de estos
riesgos se dejara en manos de los
afganos
actualmente los talibanes asedian tres
capitales de las provincias de kandahar
helmand y erat en kandahar se han
presentado múltiples ataques que
terminaron en la muerte de varios
civiles los hechos fueron condenados por
las embajadas de estados unidos y reino
unido en kabul
en spin boldak kandahar los talibanes
masacraron a decenas de civiles en
asesinatos por venganza estos asesinatos
podrían constituir crímenes de guerra
deben ser investigados y los
combatientes o comandantes talibanes
responsables deben rendir cuentas
mientras tanto el gobierno
estadounidense decidió emplear su
programa de refugiados provenientes de
afganistán
durante los últimos 13 años el
departamento de estado ha emitido más de
73.000 visas especiales para inmigrantes
afganos elegibles que hayan ayudado a
eeuu y también a sus familias sólo el
año pasado emitimos casi 8 mil visas
ahora hemos acelerado y expandido el
programa el congreso recientemente
aumentó el límite de 8 mil visas sin
ristic a peinador a causa de este
programa denominado de prioridad 2
beneficia a afganos empleados en
proyectos u organismos no
gubernamentales financiados por
washington
la decisión se da semanas antes de que
concluya la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses en el territorio afgano
y cuando hace tan sólo unos días el
primer grupo de intérpretes afganos y
sus familias llegaron a dicho país